this Justin Bieber lose his mind on
social he said the story is
right
the Biebs is now backtracking on his
Sunday night tweet challenging Tom
Cruise to a UFC cage fight too bad
because we were really looking forward
to this to his credit the 25 year old
singer kept it real about his chances
against the 56 year old action star who
still does his own stunts Bieber was in
good spirits and we're in a drew
Barrymore t-shirt as he chatted with
photog outside the LA office of his wife
Hailey's fashion line and while Tom
Cruise never responded to Bieber's
mission impossible
the singer flashed him a peace sign and
all but apologized
so why Justin challenged Tom to begin
with this is my first time on stage in
like two years
publicity maybe
just enjoined ariana grande at Coachella
and tease new music coming soon
the Biebs wants a piece of Tom Cruise
this truly is the dumbest time to be
alive it really and Jimmy Kimmel had his
own theory wonder what I think is really
going on
I think Justin Bieber got drunk and well
that's it that's what
[Applause]
[Music]